>> FORMER DONALD TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AIDE SAID SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER CAN TAKE A HIKE.
SAM NUNBERG HAS BEEN SUBPOENAED
BY MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
IN A SERIES OF WILD INTERVIEWS
TODAY, HE SAID HE'S GOING TO
REFUSE TO APPEAR.
ON MSNBC HE RIDICULED THE ENTIRE
IDEA OF THE INVESTIGATION.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN FRONT OF GRAND JURY
IF THEY DO NOT EXPLAIN TO ME WHY
I HAVE TO GO IN THERE.
THE IDEA THAT ONCE AGAIN, THAT
DONALD TRUMP COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA IS A JOKE.
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS TOO SMART TO
COLLUDE WITH DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP COULDN'T KEEP HIS
MOUTH SHUT.
>> HE'S LETTING IT ALL HANG OUT.
NOBODY HEARD OF THIS
MR. NUNBERG.
HE'S A GUY HE'S ABOUT HALF THE
AGE OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHO WAS BRIEFLY INVOLVED IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
HAS NOW HAD A SUBPOENA AND
DECIDED HE'S NOT GOING TO PLAY
ALONG.
>> HE'S A GUY IN TOWN HERE IN
NEW YORK.
HE'S GOT A LAW DEGREE.
HE PRACTICESES AS AN ATTORNEY.
HE HAPPENS TO BE A FRIEND OF
MINE.
WE'RE NOT VERY CLOSE.
I THOUGHT ABOUT CALLING HIM
TODAY.
LITERALLY THOUGHT, IF I CALL HIM
WHO KNOWS IF I GET SUCKED IN
THIS BOB MUELLER POOL.
IT'S GETTING BIGGER AND BIGGER.
>> HE'S GOT A POINT HERE.
I REGARD FEDERAL JUSTICE A
RACKET.
THEY CONVICT 97% OF THE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE SAYING TO YOU, ROLL OVER
FOR US OR WE'RE GOING TO DESTROY
YOUR LIFE.
THIS GUY IS LOOKING AT 120 YEARS
IN JAIL OR HE'LL BE SLEEPING IN
A DUMPSTER.
THERE'S SOMETHING ACTUALLY
ADMIRAL TELLING MUELLER TO STUFF
IT.
>> I DO BELIEVE YOU'RE SUBPOENA,
YOU SHOULD SHOW UP.
THAT'S PART OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A 97%
CONVICTION RATE, THAT'S NOT A
NICELY BALANCED SCALE OF
JUSTICE.
ANOTHER IS, THESE FOLKS WHO GET
BROUGHT IN FOR DISCUSSIONS TO
THE CAPITOL HILL FOR HEARINGS
THEY BRING LAWYERS IN.
IT COST LOT OF MONEY.
SAM NUNBERG HAS NO SENSE TO GO
DOWN THERE IN AN ATTORNEY.
WE TALK ON THE PHONE.
HE'S QUITE DISTRAUGHT ABOUT
THIS.
HUGE EXPENSE HE'S FACED.
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT'S OUTRAGEOUS
ABOUT THIS.
LET'S SAY YOU HAVE ONE LAWYER OR
FIVE LAWYERS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, BOB
MUELLER HAS 105 LAWYERS.
>> IF THEY RUN OUT OF MONEY,
THEY CAN PRINT MORE MONEY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOES.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT INCIDENT
RESOURCES.
>> WE'VE HEARD TODAY IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF HOURS, MUELLER IS
INVESTIGATING NOT JUST TRUMP'S
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA BUT
APPARENTLY WITH POTENTIALLY WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES TOO.
HE'S APPARENTLY MET WITH A GUY
FROM LEBANON AND UNITED
EMIRATES.
HE MAYBE COLLUDING WITH BELGIUM
AND USING COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M AMERICAN AND YOU'RE
CANADIAN.
THAT'S COLLUDING.
MAYBE WE SHOULD LEAVE THE STUDIO
NOW WHILE WE CAN.
THIS IS INSANE.
>> YOU'RE NOT COLLUDE WITH
CANADIANS.
IN CANADA WE CAN COLLUDE WITH
YOU.
>> THIS ALL STARTED OFF AS AN
INVESTIGATION TRUMP AND RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THEY FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF THIS.
WHAT AMAZES ME, MUELLER SO BUSY
TRYING TO FIND SOMEBODY THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
YET, YOU HAVE MASSIVE COLLUSION
ON THE PART OF THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE RUSSIANS.
HE'S NOT INTERESTED IN LOOKING
AT THAT.
>> YOU PUT IT THIS WAY.
YOU SAY HERE'S MUELLER AND THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT, THEY BROKEN
DOWN THE FRONT DOOR.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR CANDLE IN
THE TRUMP HOUSE.
NEXT DOOR THE DEMOCRAT HOUSE IS
A FLAME WITH RUSSIA.
>> JUST A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES,
THE RUSSIAN RESET THAT'S A
COLLUSION OF SORT.
HILLARY CLINTON HAD THE URANIUM
ONE DEAL WHICH SHE APPROVED IN
EXCHANGE FOR 20% OF U.S. URANIUM
SUPPLY TO THE KREMLIN.
>> WHY DON'T ANY OF HILLARY'S
AIDES HAVE IT TURN OVER ALL
THEIR E-MAILS.
>> IT STRIKES ME AS AMAZING.
NOT ONLY ARE THERE NO
INDICTMENTS, MUELLER IS NOT
ASKING THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE A BOEING DEAL WHERE
HILLARY GOT INVOLVED.
BOEING GIVES $900,000 TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
SHE HELPED ALL THESE AMERICAN
COMPANY TAKE A LOOK.
THOSE COMPANIES SIGNED UP, THEY
IN TURN GAVE AT LEAST
$6.5 MILLION TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
WE FIND OUT FROM PENTAGON THAT
WHOLE THING WAS A SCAM DESIGNED
TO ENGAGE ESPIONAGE TO STEAL
AMERICAN TECHNOLOGY.
NO QUESTIONS, NO DISCUSSION NO